in this video we present a set of
studies that led us to establish the
uncanny valley of haptics theory the
uncanny valley was first used to
describe a visually trigger volscian to
the hyper-realistic
avatars that were almost but not quite
perfectly human now we show that a
similar effect can be observed for our
sense of touched we generate an illusion
of spacial touch inside virtual reality
by providing synchronous vibrations of
different amplitudes to two handheld
controllers the hands are also connected
in the virtual environment by a wooden
dowel we then show a small white marble
that seems to knock on the dowel at
different locations as we vary the
vibratory sensations the touches are
felt to be located in the empty space
between the hands when we produce the
same stimulation without the marble the
apparent out of the body spatial
location of the touch sensations will
persist however where improvements in
the spatialization of touch created a
worse subjective experience than a
generic vibration of equal amplitude to
both hands the experience was improved
when the participants moved the virtual
dowel up and down thereby making them
the agent of the tactile sensations in
this paper we show for the first time
that improvements in haptics might fall
into an uncanny valley and we delineate
key features to avoid this uncanny
valley of haptics